hey everyone i'm alex and i'll be
presenting joint work with my advisor
vinod on correlation and tractable hash
functions via shift heightening
so first of all what are correlation and
tractable hash functions
so correlation and tractability is a
cryptographic security property trying
to capture the hardness
of finding input output correlations of
some sort in a hash function so formally
given a 2t area relation r so a relation
r on t inputs and t outputs
we say that a hash family h is
correlation intractable for r
if for every efficiently computable
adversary the adversary only has a
negligible chance of given a hash
function h
finding t inputs x1 through xt
such that these t inputs along with
their corresponding t hash outputs
satisfy r
so it's plausible for a hash function to
satisfy this security property
provided that the relation r is
sufficiently sparse which roughly
speaking means that there aren't too
many points in the relation
and besides this you know this is the
only real constraint
otherwise it's plausible the hash
function satisfies this property and
indeed a random function would
so uh ideally we'd like to build
correlation intractable hash functions
for as wide a class of relations as
possible
unfortunately already when they were
introduced by kennedy goldberg and
halevi they showed that there is no
single hash family h
that is correlation intractable for all
sparse relations r in particular if r is
allowed to be inefficient and if the
number of inputs t that you care about
is an unbounded polynomial function of
the input length n
so in that
in that level of generality we know that
we cannot build a correlation
interactable hash family but essentially
anything less general than that is
plausible on the table and so the
question for this work and many other
works is you know which kinds of
correlation and tractability can we
build and uh how how is it done
so before getting into that though let
me just talk a little bit about why we
care about what correlation
attractability is useful for so already
in the single input setting so t equals
one
uh they're already incredibly useful
because they give uh standard model
instantiations of the fiat mirror
heuristic
so that is there has been this cool line
of work over the last few years uh that
has built correlation interactable hash
functions and then used them to build
various kinds of non-interactive proof
and argument systems
uh that we didn't know how to build
before uh so it's been it's been very
fun working on on this this line of work
and
uh correlation tractability uh is very
essential here
so that's that's the like a main
application of correlation
interactability that has happened so far
uh but i want to talk specifically about
the multi-input case because although
it's quite
uh like unstudied there there hasn't
been much work done on it uh there have
already been a few scenarios that have
come up where multi-input correlation
and tractability has seemed quite
important
so uh the first uh example that people
came up with was this was the setting of
trying to set up a common random string
when you have many mutually distrusting
parties so yes you could have many
parties they want to agree on a common
random string but they don't trust each
other to produce a truly random string
so what you can do
is have each party send their own random
string and publish it and then use the
hash function to generate an actual
common random string given these many
inputs so that's that's one plausible
use case for multi-input correlation and
tractability uh additionally uh it's
quite related to
uh the security of like complicated
multi-step protocols especially when
there are many parties involved so it
turns out that you need a form of
multi-input correlation tractability to
hold to have any hope of the bitcoin
protocol being secure so this is not a
sufficient condition but it is a
necessary condition
so that motivates thinking about it for
sure
uh and uh
uh
also uh there was this recent work that
actually just used multi-input
correlation and tractability to prove
build a different honest majority
multi-party computation protocol
so yeah it turns out to be useful for
honest majority npc
and finally
it was also shown how to use multi-input
correlation and tractability uh in order
to build an error correcting code uh
which is computational which where the
like error correction property is only
computational that is only
computationally difficult rather than
impossible to violate the error
correction property
the the trade-off for the the on the
plus side
what what this work is able to do
is they
are able to build a code with a decoding
radius which is larger than what's
information theoretically possible so
that's pretty cool
uh so yeah so so multi-input correlation
and tractability seems to be pretty
broadly applicable as well although
we're still on like in the process of
understanding what it is good for uh but
for this for this talk i just want to
focus on the question of building uh the
tool rather than using the tool so how
do we build correlation and tractable
hash functions
so let me talk about what was previously
known before this work
so
in order to do so we need to narrow our
scope quite a bit
so we're going to for the moment focus
on the single input case so t equals one
and we're also going to further narrow
our scope from an arbitrary relation r
to functions f
so uh so in that setting
correlation and tractability for a
function f means that it's hard to find
a single input x
such that hash of x is equal to some
pre-specified function f of x
so so we've simplified the property
quite a bit uh but this is still a very
non-trivial object and and suffices for
many of the fiat mirror applications on
the previous slide and so this object we
knew how to build uh it was it was known
uh that under standard cryptographic
assumptions you could build hash
function families that are ci for
efficiently computable functions or
there's a quantifier issue so it's for
any any fixed time bound you can build a
hash family that is ci for functions
that take that much time to compute
so this was known
and uh just like a word on on how it was
accomplished uh the idea was to think of
the description of a hash function as
being an encrypted function
uh and in the security proof you would
think of the encrypted function as the
the function being encrypted as being
the function that you're trying to avoid
in the security property
and the hash family was constructed so
that hash of x would output an
encryption of a message
which like guaranteed that the string
would not match f x that the ciphertext
string would not match f of x
so uh so in the original construction
we did this by assuming that we had a
fully homomorphic encryption scheme that
satisfied a circular security property
that is that satisfied some security
property where the message you were
encrypting was related to the secret key
of the encryption scheme uh so it was
nice but it had a stronger than like a
slightly stronger security property than
we wanted
and uh and this was later uh improved by
picard and sheehan to remove the
circular security assumption and just
rely on plane learning with errors they
did this by uh carefully instantiating
like special purpose variants
like a homomorphic encryption scheme
with some
special
a bit hard to describe properties uh
that
removed the need for the circular
security assumption
so this is very clever uh but the
conceptual simplicity was lost a bit in
this in this construction
uh so that was for the single input case
and then in the multi-input case much
less is known
so
in a joint work with justin holmgren
we constructed various kinds of
multi-input correlation intractable hash
families
but we required very strong
computational assumptions in order to
build them stronger than standard uh and
we'd like to
rely on standard assumptions
uh
and then uh there is just one other
thing to mention which is that so
like because correlation interactability
is so
general there are going to be some
special cases that we that we knew how
to handle before in particular if you
just think about
relations that only
touch the outputs so relations that yeah
that that just check some properties of
the collection of t outputs
uh then as special cases you recover
some uh old security properties uh like
collision resistance that we certainly
knew how to build and then mark zandry
has a work which generalizes this to
just all output-only relations
so so this is what we knew how to build
uh previously it's it's quite a limited
class
uh of multi-input relations that we knew
uh and uh from standard assumptions
anyway
so so now let me talk about what we do
in this work
so
uh like in a nutshell what we do is we
give a new framework for building
correlation interactable hash functions
we no longer
use this homomorphic encryption approach
uh we instead turn to another like
permitted from cryptography called shift
hiding shiftable functions which is
related to
constrained pseudo-random functions so
that that's the area that we're jumping
to instead
and uh
and we show that they can be used as
well to build correlation and tractable
hash functions
um so so what do we get out of it so
first of all we get a different
construction of single input correlation
and tractability from lattice
assumptions
uh this is so this is just for covering
the top line result of uh prior work
but i think the security for the
construction and proofs are are very
clean and i think it's it's nice to know
but in terms of new results
we build various kinds of multi-input
correlation interactability uh first a
class of constructions from lattice
assumptions again
and then a broader class of
constructions from uh making use of
indistinguishability obfuscation uh plus
additional standard assumptions
uh so yeah these are the new things that
we built
uh let me uh let me give a little more
details about what these new
constructions are
uh so
uh so let me let me define a class of
relations that we're able to cancel to
capture uh which which uh we called
shifted linear relations
uh so r
a relation r on t inputs and t outputs
is an f shifted linear relation if it's
checking
that
the following kind of linear relation
holds between the inputs and outputs so
it's checking whether the sum
of the outputs
is equal to the sum of f
of the inputs the sum of f x i
uh so yeah it's just checking some it's
checking a linear function on the
collection of outputs
and the collection of
f of
the inputs
uh yeah so this is some class of
relations and if t equals one this just
recovers
uh just functions uh in the single input
case
uh but it's uh it's a
broader class of relations in the many
input case
so one thing that we're able to do is
that under the lw assumption plus
like plus another lattice assumption
which also basically follows from lwe
we build hash functions that are
correlation intractable for this class
of relations
and uh we get something a bit stronger
than this actually like the you can
consider versions uh of these kinds of
relations where you're allowed to take
weighted linear combinations rather than
just taking a sum
so these are the kinds of relations that
we can
handle just from lwe
and then here's the class that we're
able to handle making additional use of
obfuscation
so
we just generalize basically from linear
to non-linear
so uh so a relation
is a
shifted relation uh where it's shifted
by a function f
and the like base relation is some
output only relation r sub out
uh if the relation r is just the
collection of x i's and y i's
uh where
these shifted outputs y i minus f x i
satisfy the output relation r sub out
so just just as an example you can you
know take r sub out to be like the
collision resistance relation
uh and then you basically get and that
that's an example of something already
from the previous slide it's some it's
some linear function on these y i's
minus f of x i's uh
that's just an example but but in
general you can let r sub out be an
arbitrary sparse output relation and uh
you'll get something interesting here
and uh assuming i o and and uh some like
mild additional assumptions then we can
build correlation and tractable hash
functions for all of these relations
uh and i also want to mention
that
this also like our our technique here
implies new results even in the single
input setting so we can build uh
correlation and trackable hash functions
in the single input setting just based
on io plus one away permutations uh
which is mostly just like a theoretical
separation uh because a
like
uh i o and one permutations don't imply
any form of two input correlation
intractability so it's like a separation
between single input and two input
correlation interactability
and also uh because of this recent work
of jane lynn and sahai uh this also
gives an approach for building uh
correlation and tractability that does
not rely on the learning with errors
problem
because you can instantiate the morning
permutations using discrete log
okay so uh so these are
our new results are like concrete new
results uh so now let me uh
just explain how we get them uh so the
the main tool which i already mentioned
uh is this object called shift hiding
shiftable functions which is a special
kind of pseudorandom function
so so a function family capital f
indexed by a secret key sk
uh is shift hiding if it's if it
satisfies some kind of programmability
property
so the the property is that there's this
algorithm shift
which takes the
initial secret key for the prf
and takes a function f
and outputs some shifted key case of f
such that the following two properties
hold
first of all if you evaluate the
pseudorandom function using the shifted
key case of f
you should get
the original prf evaluation of x
shifted by f of x
so
in the actual construction this property
will also be computational so it will
just be hard to find in x such that this
is not true but you can just think of it
as just as being always true for
convenience
so this is the shifts correctness
property
and then second
the the family should be shift hiding
which means that the shifted key case of
f should not tell you anything about
what f is so in the security game you're
just given a key
and
and the property says that for any two
functions f and g k sub f and k sub g
are computationally indistinguishable
so uh so this is the object it's some
yeah it's
as i said it's a pseudorandom function
family with some sort of programmability
property
uh and so uh and so it was known in fact
before any correlation intractable hash
functions were really constructed
uh that the that shift hiding shiftable
functions exist under the lwe assumption
uh plus this one-dimensional cis
assumption as well
yeah so so this this was known and we
end up showing in this work that this
hash function or sorry that this
pseudorandom function family which
already existed uh turns out to also
solve the correlation tractability
problem essentially for free
uh so so yeah let's let's talk about
how that works so so essentially here's
the key lemma for the whole for the
whole uh paper uh and the lemma is also
like extremely easy to prove
so consider the following construction
like start with some pseudorandom
function family or some or we're going
to assume it's a shift hiding so yeah so
assume you have a family like this
then we're going to define a hash family
h
where
like a hash key
is just a shifted key
from the shsf
uh
where the the key has been shifted on
like a trivial zero function so it
hasn't really been shifted at all but it
is a shift key
so then hashing an input is just
applying the prf using the trivial
shifted key
so so that that's the that's the hash
function sort of like the only thing you
could write down
uh and then the claim
is that if
the family is shift hiding
and
if it satisfies a one-wayness property
namely it's hard to invert zero
like according like it's hard to invert
this function on the output zero
you know if these two assumptions are
true
then the hash family is correlation
intractable for all efficiently
computable functions
uh so
it's yeah
it's very nice it just says that uh
with this one like additional assumption
that you get correlation and
tractability
so uh so here's the proof uh or sorry
yeah so in other words like what's going
on here is that
like shift hiding shiftable functions
give you a correlation and tractability
self-reduction
like it says that to gets
correlation and tractability for all f
it suffices just to handle the case f
equals zero like the trivial case which
corresponds basically to the
function family being a one-way function
uh yeah so so that's that's what this is
saying
uh but
i
like there there is a caveat here which
is that like you need the shift hiding
shiftable function itself to be one way
and the way this is like phrased is that
we want it to be one way given the
secret key in the clear so this is a
very interesting question it's come up
before you know like what happens when
you give out the secret key
uh
for a for a prf like can you argue that
it's a one-way function this has been
analyzed uh in the case of ggm
specifically a few years ago uh but in
general it's a pretty open question like
when this is possible uh but we're able
to show it holds for particular
pseudorandom function families that we
built
okay but anyway let me let me explain
the proof of this lemma it's yeah it's
like three lines
uh here it is suppose that the adversary
violates the correlation interactability
property
which means that it finds an input x
with some non-negligible probability
such that hash of x is equal to f x for
some pre-specified f
and remember that hash of x is just a
prf evaluation of x on this trivial
shifted key
so that that's what we assume
then
we just invoke
the two properties of the shift hiding
shiftable function so first of all by
the shift hiding property we should be
able to replace the trivial shifted key
with the key shifted at f case of f and
this
change should be undetectable
so that means that when the adversary is
given k sub f it still finds
an input such that hash of x equals f of
x but now this hash of x is equal to the
f shifted evaluation
but we know
that the f shifted evaluation is just
equal to the actual prf evaluation plus
f of x
so just plugging that into the equation
we immediately see that this means that
the prf evaluation of x
is equal to zero uh we also assumed that
it's hard to invert zero
uh so this is a contradiction and that's
it it's like a it's like a very
syntactic proof
and uh and it says that you get
correlation interactability for all f at
the end so i think this is very nice
uh so so this is the proof of the key
lemma and so
the rest of the paper is about thinking
about just building uh building the
objects that that was assumed in this
lemma
uh so okay so this is this is just for
the single input case so
like what you also need to do is
formulate and prove the multi-input
version of this lemma which is something
we do but i'm not going to cover in this
talk
but it's it's it's very similar to this
lemma
so uh so that's
that's the reduction so now all we need
to do is find shift hiding shiftable
functions that are also one-way
functions essentially
so
so i'll just explain one of the
constructions i'll explain the lwb based
construction and there we just show that
the original uh shift hiding shifts of a
function based on lwe was already one
way and so this this shsf that already
existed solved the correlation
tractability problem
so
in fact what we end up showing in order
to get the results for multi-input
correlation interactability uh is that
we show that it's actually a collision
resistant hash function
and
more generally just solves like sorry
like uh like uh
satisfies uh this property called some
resistance which is says that
it's uh computationally hard to find
distinct inputs x1 through xt
such that any pre-specified
weighted linear combination of the hash
values uh is equal to zero sorry the
slide has a mistake uh this uh
the right hand side of the equation
should just be zero so it's
hard to find uh t inputs whose weighted
such that the weighted linear
combination of the hash outputs is equal
to zero
uh then by the self-reduction we get
this more general property where the f
with an allowed f dependence in the uh
in the equation
okay so so that's what we want to uh
show about the the the lw based hash
func lw based shsf
and so i'll just sketch the proof uh
that it's one way or that it's hard to
invert zero
uh and so i'm throwing a bunch of
detailed under the rug here but
roughly speaking this is what the
function looks like the function that we
want to show is one way
the input is x
and the key to the function
is specified by
two random vectors s and u
along with a collection
of many
random matrices
which is just represented by this a a is
a is a collection of matrices
then the the function output
is a rounded version
of a
vector matrix product so this there's
the vector s g plus u which you you
should just think of as a random vector
and then g inverse of a of a sub x so g
is g this is a bit decomposition
g inverse of a sub x is a
binary matrix so it's just one it's one
matrix
with binary inputs so binary entries
and
i'm skipping over a bunch of details but
a sub x is some matrix generated using
this gadget
gadget homomorphism methodology
okay so
so it's a random vector times a
matrix with small entries
uh so we want to show that that it's
hard to invert zero uh it's hard to
invert this function at zero so so let's
let's see why
so suppose that we could invert suppose
that we found x such that f of x equals
zero
uh
like taking out the like rounding
operation what this means is that this
vector matrix product is a short vector
and so we're going to use this to
violate some computational assumptions
so
to do this there are two cases
uh
if this matrix a sub x is non-zero
then we have solved
a short integer solution problem where
the the problem is specified by this
random vector sg plus u so sg plus u
specifies like a problem like of finding
uh a vector
whose inner product with this vector is
very small
and so this is this is a one-dimensional
cis problem which turns out to be hard
and uh and so if a sub x is non-zero
then like inverting f means that we've
solved this kind of cis problem so that
can't happen
so the other case is that a sub x equals
zero
and in this case we show that you solve
a different cis problem where the the
instance to the cis problem is now the
collect is now like specified by this
collection of matrices a
and uh and like a sub x equals zero
turns out to be like something you can
phrase uh as a solution to a cis problem
as well so this one is a bit trickier
and i won't get into the details here
but but it turns out that you can show
this would violate a difference this
assumption
so this is the like high level idea of
uh of how the proof goes
so uh that's that's all i wanted to say
so now just let me conclude
um so as i said before like what this
paper is doing is it's giving a new
framework for building correlation and
tractable hash functions where the main
tool
for building
the hash functions
are the shift hiding shiftable functions
and so we show that they that shift
hiding gives you a self-reduction for
correlation and tractability which
reduces correlation and tractability in
like hard cases quote-unquote to
correlation and tractability into easier
cases and this gives a methodology for
building them in various settings
uh so like
as a result
we make some progress but like on on the
following two questions like can we
build correlation and tractable hash
functions from weaker or at least
incomparable computational assumptions
to what was known before
uh
and
and uh the other question is you know
which relations uh
is correlation and tractability
instantiable for in any like under any
assumption
so uh it's like these are the goals that
we had in mind and and i think that this
is a
neat new approach for you know maybe
resolving these questions or making
progress on these questions but i think
that
there's a lot left to be done in the
area
and these two questions are still quite
far from being solved so i think uh
hopeful hopefully these techniques lead
to further progress in the future
uh and then yeah so specifically you
know like one like really nice goal for
the future would be to actually build
forms of multi-input correlation and
tractability that actually connects to
either the applications that i described
at the beginning of the talk or to new
applications uh like for like specific
uh
like cryptographic primitives or
protocols beyond correlation
interactability itself
so that's everything thanks for
listening